I had the pleasure of working with this
gentleman for a couple of Thursday night
football seasons and covered him for
many a season in his time as a head
coach in the National Football League he
and his wife Lauren have two books that
you should get at team Dungy comm
available coming up in the first week of
August they are two children's books
that we will discuss when his wife comes
out shortly but I want to welcome to the
show in studio police to have you Tony
Dungy Thank You Ritz great been here and
what it what it said the snake hazing I
really appreciate you saying that
thank you you know it's so it's so
amazing just I look down and I'm I see
two times Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
13 and then Super Bowl or they 141 that
is unbelievable
13 was my second year with the Steelers
and we won and that was their third one
and and you knew things were gonna go
for a while and so I'm thinking hey this
this is pretty easy you come show up get
a Super Bowl ring I'll probably get
three or four more it was uh 28 years 29
years before I got back to another one
what was it like strolling around that
locker you know what it was incredible
you walk in as a young guy and Donnie
shell is sitting on my right Franco
Harris is one one stall down Lynn Swann
John Stallworth Joe green Mel Blount I
mean just who's who of nfl superstars
but the the chemistry and the
camaraderie was so special and took a
long time I was always looking for that
again to have talent come together with
teamwork and that that's what made it so
special and started with our Rooney
senior I mean he set the tone for how
that team was gonna be coached and old
Dan Rooney it was it was phenomenal
experience I know you're a humble man
but I will ask this question anyway what
if somebody had come up to you whispered
in your ear you're gonna have a bust
Hall of Fame one day with all pretty
much every name you just mentioned that
was the opening to my Hall of Fame
acceptance speech that I'm the tenth guy
from that team to be inducted and you
would have won millions of dollars have
you ever bet on that there there was no
wait but it was just I learned so much
being in that organization being around
those guys and it was just God's timing
for me to be there and learn and end up
putting that to use as a coach I want to
ask you about the the decision that
Terrell Owens is made about not
appearing for his induction weekend Tony
and what your thoughts are on that I
feel sorry for Terrell Owens I really do
he's hurt that he didn't go in on the
first ballot well neither did Marvin
Harrison or Chris Carter or Tim Brown or
art monk so it happens but what is what
he's gonna miss not being there is not
for himself but your family your friends
your coaches your teammates people who
want to celebrate with you and I was
there two years ago with my entire
family with my high school coach with
people from my hometown
kids I grew up with and they got a
chance to celebrate that's what tio is
gonna miss and he may not miss it but
all of those people will it just seems
that there's something other than just
what you've described as to the reason
why he's not doing this have you heard
any PI have not heard anything and I
think it's just hurt feelings and I I'm
sorry I just feel badly for him because
he's gonna miss out on a great weekend
well I I you know do you think that this
might set a trend do you think other
players I absolutely can't see anyone
else doing this it's such a unique
situation it's such a thrill to go in
and I guess everyone would like to go in
on the first ballot I went in on the
third ballot and you're just ecstatic
when you get the call and you know I
just I really don't understand
I don't couple other football subjects I
want to hit with you before your wife
comes out and we talk about these books
here the national anthem
I guess policy that came out in May now
yesterday the league is essentially
saying we're gonna put that on hold
while we talk to the players are so seen
about race like that should have been
the first step the very first step
when they're trying to formulate this
together hey let's call the player reps
in let's get ten or twelve of our
veteran players let's all of us sit down
Management Council the league office
let's talk this through here what do you
guys want to get across I know you want
to be a voice for those that don't have
a voice so how can we do this how can we
get your points across and do it in a
different way
and I think it had ever and it'll happen
now that everybody's gonna come together
they'll come up with a good way to do
this well I mean what is the answer I
mean just even me discussing it earlier
my Twitter feeds like well I don't watch
the NFL to have somebody protest before
the game or if you tried that in your
workplace let's see how that would go
and also they have every right to take a
knee I mean there's both sides to the
coin and I've heard it too from from
people I've been there I try to put
myself in position if I was coaching
still what would I do and I think I
would go to the players and say hey what
are you really trying to get across
let's go to our ownership let's go to
Jim Irsay and say you know what let's
have a press conference let's bring
everyone in let's talk about these
issues here's what's on your mind here's
how we're going to attack it get
together players coaches management and
get these things out yep I talk to
people all the time I'm through with the
NFL because you know I don't want to see
these players doing this of the other
side of the coin I'm through with the
NFL because the management is trying to
tell the players they have to do a B and
C I think coming together is the way to
approach it not pulling apart not being
in separate cam have you spoken to the
commissioner or anybody and I have
talked to the Commissioner a little bit
about this boy Vincent and you know
they're searching they're trying to put
it together I don't think anybody's sure
of exactly what to do and so my advice
is come together get a lot of ideas get
a lot of counsel before you make a
decision and then before you know
Lauren's standing by good to see you
Lauren she sits east over there and will
be joining us in a second together the
last football subject I want to hit you
on to me it's fascinating coming out of
the draft Lamar Jackson
and what he did previously and what he
can do in this league for a team that
was so lacking in dynamic plays from
scrimmage with the Ravens how does it
work if they do have Flacco under center
and are still gonna call Lamar a
quarterback how do you think this is
gonna work it'll be interesting I think
if you draft Lamar Jackson in the second
or third round then you can do all these
gimmicky things and say here's a guy we
got he's a special talent we just want
to get him the ball but to me when you
trade up into the first round to take
him you're saying this is gonna be our
quarterback so you got to find a way to
make him the quarterback now maybe
you'll do what they Stiller's did with
Kordell Stewart hey until he's we feel
he's ready we can do this this and this
to get him involved but at some point
he's got to be your quarterback he
doesn't want to be a slash though no he
doesn't and when you draft him in the
first round you're saying you're not a
slash you're our future quarterback so
to me you got to get him as much work at
quarterback as you can how do you do
that put him in the lineup
deshaun Watson was all last year on our
show I'm saying why is this guy not
playing you know they finally put him in
and they said wow this is special I
think when Lamar Jackson gets in the
lineup whenever that is in Baltimore
you're gonna say this is pretty special
I know I guess it's one thing to say to
Tom Savage sit there's another flat a
ring and it's different in a big
contract but when you draft him in the
first round it effectively that that's
what you're saying when when the Packers
drafted Aaron Rodgers in the first round
you didn't know when but at some point
he's taken over for Brett Favre Tony
Dungy here at Tony Dungy at Lauren Dungy
on Twitter get him set to join us good
to see you Lauren kids thank you for
being you bet you bet Maria finds
courage Austin plays fair couple
children's books the dun G's will join
us in 60 seconds together here on the
Rich Eisen show Lauren Dungey is sitting
right here on the set with Tony good to
see you thank you it's great to be here
you bet you bet and you and Tony have
written a
book together or two again obviously you
wrote a book about marriage that was the
New York Times bestseller before back in
2014 now there's two children's books
Austen plays fair and Maria finds
courage Tony Dungy along with Lauren
Dungey here on the show why'd you do
this why'd you guys do this together you
think Tony and I both have a passion and
a love for reading and we want to pass
that on to kids we want to inspire them
and encourage them to read so we thought
it was an excellent opportunity to do
that through reading through writing a
book then you sit down together and just
hammer out what we do when I was
coaching the books Lauren and a lot of
the other wives used to read in
elementary schools on Tuesdays and they
came back and said you know what we're
really having difficulty finding books
number one with diverse characters were
that have a good message that are fun
and that's what we want to read so
seeing that there was a shortage of that
that's how we kind of came to attack and
you're an early childhood educational
specialist is that what you would say is
your your endeavor or my passion and my
title yeah sure and definitely saw a
need for children to be exposed to good
books that were fun and entertaining but
also had messages behind them that they
could relate to and learn from them so
we wrote the two books and we're excited
about it do you find it's difficult to
go in and pitch a a children's book
these days I think okay good
I'm glad to hear that yeah yeah I mean
you you went in and you say hey we got a
couple ideas and ideas we think that
children can relate to the stories all
kids have issues and they need support
they need guidance to work through those
challenges and so through stories they
can read them relate to them and to see
how adults coaches mentors can help them
through those challenges and we did it
through storytelling yeah and sports
obviously some sports stories right here
we went to harvest house publishers and
kind of said this is the concept and
I did and they loved it and they've been
been great to work with and actually we
were talking to you yesterday they've
got a contest going online you can go to
team done z.com enter in and your child
can be in the next book that we write
okay so exciting is that sort of a
contest yeah okay Chris you want you
want me to put you in instead of my
three children what would you like me to
do I mean it's for the kids
I don't know if you have the temperament
for that to be quite honest I mean I run
hot which I think you know coach Gruden
understands that I think he could do
that yeah okay very good so I'll just
leave it to my children so people could
go to two teams right now yeah they can
pre-order the book Ryan there's a little
slot you sign up and if your your name
is entered then you can have your child
as a character in the in the next book
we do okay team Dungey calm the Tony the
team Dungey book series Austen plays
fair and Maria finds courage as we've
got Tony and Lauren Dungey here on the
Rich Eisen show what was the Hall of
Fame weekend like from your perspective
Lauren it was so exciting there was so
much excitement in the air and a lot of
athletes coming together to celebrate
this occasion and then of course as a
wife of a Hall of Famer
I can't even explain how we were just so
thrilled for this opportunity to be here
and to celebrate with Tony well I mean
it was a crowning achievement for you
too I mean well thank you you're welcome
I mean it's a team effort the whole
family's behind this but you know Tony's
certainly is well deserving of this
honor and we were thrilled to be a part
of it okay if you don't mind I'm gonna
put you on the spot just a little bit
just a little excited give that heads up
we always ask coaches who's your
favorite player he ever coached who was
a favorite player of yours that Tony
ever coached great question I'm not
gonna answer for you but I think I feel
like this is like the newlywed game
feel like we should do right now all
right the question is I enjoyed watching
him coach Peyton Manning that's my
answer
I was gonna say Ward done work came
first and you know the story his mom had
gotten killed in a robbery
he's got teenage siblings and he's gonna
go out and win Rookie of the Year for us
but he's asking Lauren Kent can you go
to the PTA meeting with me can you get
my kids signed up yes and it was it was
neat to be involved with work he had
such a heart for his siblings and to see
how he balanced that playing so well in
the field but they're also rushing home
to be involved with the kids and that
was amazing so no I know he he he builds
houses for Habitat ganymede deshaun
Watson grew up in one of those houses
that's that it was so amazing I you know
every year I would talk to our players
hey we want to do more than just win
Super Bowls we want to make the
community a better place to live after
Ward's first year he came in and said I
grew up moving around Apartments never
had a home I have this heart for single
moms I want to do something and he
decided he was going to start this
foundation they would find a home make
the down payment furnish it stock the
refrigerator give the single mom the
keys and say okay we've got to started
now you've got to take it from here and
he's done a hundred and fifty plus of
those including the home to show so what
do you mean he asked you to go to PTA
meetings to support and you know he
initially called just to get advice over
the phone what can I do I'm struggling
with my brother and sister and they're
not too excited about school but I want
them I know the value of education and
what can I do how can you help me out I
said you know what I'll go with you I'll
support you in that endeavor so helping
them acclimate to the Tampa area and the
schools and I was impressed by me mark
and then we had kids and we both of us
and we're trying to get them going as
young kids and he's playing practicing
worried about his three teenage siblings
and trying to get them going and
established and it was just amazing do
you want to get an ownership now you
read that somewhere he's thinking about
everyone wants to do that yeah for sure
okay maybe they'll be the next book
Maria finds courage and an Austen place
fare now this isn't the coach this isn't
to Austin place fare any shot at the
Patriots organization is it Tony New
York Times bestselling authors Tony and
Lauren Dungy these are two books go to
team Dungy dot-com to not only order
these books that are available on August
7th but to throw your name in the mix
and have your child featured in the next
would any hint and what the books are
gonna be about the next one's you know
not not yet we've actually got a couple
coming out that are already in the works
with this this next one that we write
with the the new person we haven't
figured we're waiting for that special
character to be included fantastic well
thank you him for including this show
and then the podcast I do with my wife
who unfortunately was on the East Coast
thanks for including us in your tour now
you're an out again I don't mean to harp
on it but you are heading to a cooking
show is that actually not just the
cooking so okay green thumb or something
like that
very good good to see you guys I guess I
will be seeing you Tony next at the Hall
of Fame yes okay and of course you and
Rodney Harrison I believe Tirico this
year right foot football night in
America before al and Chris and and and
the rest of the gang go at it on Sunday
Night Football I guess it includes Terry
McAuley this year too I think ruly
fantastic the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience